Oh God what is this that is a pure chunk
of industrial compound Oh
oh that's thick what almost like broiled
steak the first bite I was like totally
into it and then the flavor actually
came very salty I like it okay it's like
a slim jim
there's one gonna kind of your container
which does not bode well looks like
chocolate like it should be sweet
I'm smell sweet it smells like something
of which would put in a potion oh yeah
look at that
wipe it open how much is customary to
use this most like a glass of red wine
that's been left out like two hours
going for it
Oh awful I like this too you should have
known then that was bad but I was just
eating the toast they're both terrible
and then it becomes a question of the
degree with which they're terrible
what's happening in these countries that
like this is what they need to eat
there's like so many breakfast options
the winner is Vegemite I like Marmite
better you know this is the winner and
that's not bad this one is too much salt
in your morning and it can go to hell
this wins by a bajillion winner I'm
gonna say this one ivote Marmite I'm
gonna go with Vegemite Vegemite is
better just because it's it's less which
is cool